[Musique]
à ce jour docteur strange est
certainement le personnage le plus
impressionnant est le plus important du
mc eu élément clé de la fin de l'avenger
simfinity war le sorcier a donné la
pierre du temps atano ce qui lui permit
de terminer son ascension et donc de
tuer la moitié des habitants de
l'univers je vous avais déjà proposé et
vidéo complète sur le plan 40 est le
docteur puisqu'il a vu plus de 14
millions de futurs différents dont
seulement 1 ou les avenger serait
vainqueur face à la noce
ma vidéo tournée énormément autour de
tony stark entre man et captain marvel
dans avengers 4 nous savons que tony
stark sera toujours présent et que son
rôle sera important iron man se mariera
avec pepper et auront probablement un
enfant après tout avengers kate se
situerait quelques années plus tard
avengers 3 je ne change pas d'avis
concernant captain marvel
elle est pour moi la héroïne clé de ce
prochain à 20h et sera le point final du
combat contre thanos cependant elle ne
peut vaincre seul le titan et sera
évidemment épaulé par les autres héros
de la saga est justement une certaine
révélation du film avengers 4 ha étaient
voilées dans un récent super picsou
magazine
je fais d'ailleurs un gros bisou à
o'neill inc qui est la bonne et kim a
partagé cette révélation dans ce bouquin
une phrase fait réellement réfléchir
concernant avengers 4 et j'aimerais en
débattre avec vous s'il n'a pas pu être
présent dans avengers infinity ward il
devrait participer avec sa copine la
guêpe au prochain film des avengers
prévu pour sortir en avril 2019 on
murmure que ant man et le docteur
strange seraient associés et poursuivre
l étude de la dimension quantique afin
de venir à bout de thanos j'en parlais
déjà dans ma précédente vidéo mais si
antoine de et captain marvel sorte après
une fuite hiwar mais se passe
chronologiquement avant ce dernier sait
qu'ils doivent apporter des réponses
le chant quantique est une de ces
solutions cela en est certain concernant
docteur strange nous savons que le héros
du mc eut disparu reviendront par on ne
sait quel moyen mais ils reviendront
voyage dans le temps dimension
résurrection pas de réponse pour le
moment mais benedict cumberbatch
l'acteur du docteur a bien confirmé sa
présence dans le quatrième opus des
avengers
si certains veulent être rassurés bref
strange est comme un dieu
il est l'élément clé d'avengers et celui
qui mènera la danse puisqu'il est le
seul à connaître le réel moyen de gagner
face à tan hausse au vu de la
déclaration du picsou magazine s'il
s'associe avec antoine si qu'il est une
nécessité à la victoire face à la noce
enfin plutôt le champ quantique les deux
protagonistes possède un lien encore
inconnue à leurs yeux et pourtant si
évident kevin feige le directeur de
marvel la même affirmé réfléchissez deux
minutes
qu'est ce que le chant quantique c'est
une dimension parallèle atteignable en
devenant le plus petit possible une
dimension où le temps et l'espace sont
nulles et quelle énorme intrigue amène
le film de doctor strange et qui lui
permet de se lier athmane les dimensions
parallèles évidemment freine sera
bientôt en mesure de maîtriser les
dimensions et pourrait justement
apprendre à les maîtriser grâce à
antoine et le chant quantique évidemment
mais du coup à quoi servirait de
maîtriser le champ quantique et pourquoi
ce trench intéresserait-il autant pour
réaliser son plan comme vous le savez le
mc ou n'est pas une adaptation des
comics james gunn avait d'ailleurs
affirmé qu'il n'y avait aucun intérêt de
retranscrire les comics en film
ils veulent créer de la surprise c'est
d'ailleurs pour ceux ci qu'adam warlock
ne sera pas dans avengers 4 bref le
champ quantique dans le mc huet en fait
l'équivalent du micro verse dans les
comics nous le remarquons au fait que le
moyen d'accéder au micro verse est le
même que celui du chant quantique via un
très grand rétrécissement le micro verse
est un moyen d'accéder à énormément de
dimensions parallèles et donc de
pourquoi pas récupérer les pierres
d'infinité d'autres dimensions ou bien
la 7e pierre permettant de résister aux
six autres ou encore tout simplement
enfermé tanoh dans cette dernière
puisqu'on peut y être enfermé pour
l'éternité hashtag janet van dyne une
multitude de possibilités existent et je
vous laisserai imaginer ses réponses par
vous même et je vous invite à me les
partager dans les commentaires
nous savons que quand man sera beaucoup
plus puissant et expérimenté par rapport
à son premier film de plus tous les
personnages absents d'avengers trois
seront très mise en avant dans avengers
4,60 man la guêpe
dell marvell au gayant ronin et j'en
passe bien évidemment les autres avant
just restants auront aussi leur rôle à
jouer et n'oubliez pas que des morts
arriveront en tout cas si strange a
besoin de s'allier à othman c'est qu'il
ya une raison
j'espère en tout cas que ma vidéo vous
aura plu nous reparlerons d'autres
mystères de marvel dans une prochaine
vidéo
j'aimerais notamment vous parlez de la
phase 4 de marvel merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo j'ai récemment
ouvert un utile pour ceux qui ne
sauraient pas c'est un excellent moyen
de soutenir vos vidéaste favori
financièrement sans débourser un seul
centime mais seulement un petit peu de
votre temps
le lien est disponible dans la
description suivez moi sur twitter et
abonnez-vous à la chaîne cet argot rock
et que le line up soit avec vous
[Musique]